tristan mckenzie on the hill today in
game one for the indians against the
royals in a double header as the indians
get set to open up their final home
stand of 2021.
this guy has just been pounding the
strike zone and he makes it look
effortless
on the ground left side and through
and mirrorfield begins the doubleheader
with a single to left
the o2 pitch swing and a miss got him on
a curveball and nikki lopez strikes out
for out number one
does not go and the ball is banged to
left field for a base hit mayorfield
will stop at second base and the royals
have two on with one out here in the
first inning
hit high in the year to left field back
goes oscar mercado
and makes the catch the runners have to
hold two down runner goes at second
and a high chopper to shore
quick throw it's close the call is safe
a run scores for the moment we'll see if
the indians challenge it was
a bang bang play at first base
they're gonna challenge it and i think
they might have them
here is the decision
and he is out to end the inning let's go
brady singer will be making his 26th
start of the year his record is 4 and 10
with the 485 era so ramirez to first
two down in the first no score for fran
mill reyes
and a ground ball single that'll send
hosie all the way to third
and the indians have him at the corners
with two down
oh it hit him on the foot
and so now the bases are loaded
and a fastball catches the outside
corner so he set him up with the sliders
and cleveland leaves the bases loaded in
first
the 1-1
monday swings and hits it through the
hole in between the second baseman and
shortstop into right field so the royals
with a speed guy on again
and there goes mondi the pitch is high
comes in on a bounce
and monday is in there
he goes down hacking
there goes monday to third and hedges is
late and monday has stolen two in this
inning two and one on dozier hunter had
seven hits on the home stand
and he got a fastball and he got on top
of it and that ball is way back into the
bleachers
hunter dozier with two down it's a
two-run home run
and the royals take a two-nothing lead
against mckenzie in the second oh yeah
bulldoze your way out of the ballpark
there on that high fastball that'll
weigh two down to oscar mercado
[Applause]
up the middle nikki lopez cuts it off
and throws in time and brady singer gets
the lower third of the order one two
three in the second
and it's out over the plate and nikki
lines it into center field so he's been
on base now for 29 consecutive games and
that'll bring up another red hot hitter
that's andrew benintendi
oh
deep right center field and andrew
benintendi
it's a two-run home run in the third
inning
he has driven in 23 this month and the
royals have a pair of two run home runs
against mckenzie and they lead four
nothing
[Music]
strong going up the middle and
backhanded by merrifield no chance to
get the speedster and the indians get
their laid off man aboard for the second
time tonight
2-2 pitch and it's a slider bounce to
the right side what mayerfield has it
goes to nikki at second for one that's
all they'll get
got him with a slider away so brady
singer has three scoreless innings
pitching with a four nothing lead
and he's going to give taylor a lead off
walk
taylor's running and he will be in there
and that's three stolen bases for the
royals today
hold on the ground to the right side
so o'hearn will get taylor to third with
one out all right so now the royals with
a runner and third one out and one of
the early heroes in this doubleheader
hunter dozier
dozier goes the other way and that's
down hunter dozier is driven in three
so taylor's lead off walk at stolen base
leads to a run
that is strikeout number four beauty
that's a swing
that's a ten pitch one two three bottom
of the fourth for singer
with five strikeouts
[Applause]
that is going to be down for a hit nikki
lopez
has his second hit he's on to begin the
fifth nobody down top of the fifth of a
seven inning game royals up five nothing
balling two strikes salvi waits
now the pitch and a breaking ball is hit
high and deep left center field that's
way back and that ball is gone
number 46
for salvador perez
and the royals lead is 7-0 that makes
salvi second all-time in royals history
breaking a tie with mike sweeney
so salvia has 198
and that's the most home runs
in major league history
by a primary catcher meaning
a player who caught 75 percent of the
total games he was in a tie with johnny
bench
2-1 pitch high
deep
back goes dozier can't make the play
it's up into the seats for a ground rule
double
and the indians have runners at second
and third with one out
here in the fifth inning two down in the
inning the runners still at second and
third and here's jose ramirez
and a line drive single into center
field there goes the shutout the indians
get two on the board with a two out rbi
single by jose ramirez two away in the
bottom of the sixth
back to the middle and nikki lopez is
there
that's an eight pitch one two three
bottom of the sixth
seven two royals to the seventh the two
oh
swinging a topper off the end of the bat
back toward the mound henches will lob
to first and another impressive inning
for sam hentges brady singer is getting
ready for the bottom of the seventh
inning six innings two runs one walk and
seven strikeouts
going for his first complete game
nikki lopez fields throws and there are
two down
oscar mercado is over three automatic
this is huge
the royals take game one and the
doubleheader and the road trip begins
with mike matheny only needing one
pitcher to get through game one
outstanding performance brady singer